hello today we're going to look at
starting pepper panics
if you read the article
you've got some tips i'm going to do two
different boards i'm going to do one
that's fairly easy
this is level 49.
this is a mr clause level
there's only a few colors of peppers on
this board and by making matches you can
pretty easily
start a pepper panic so
to start out i'm going to make a
l-shaped match
i'm going to try to grow the green
peppers as fast as possible
you can see that the other matches are
happening as the peppers fall
so we're gonna
looks like the yellow peppers now are
pretty far grown
so we can go there
all right so as you can see whenever
you get one color or several are
grown you can
just explode one of that color and then
that'll automatically get you ready
to start your panic so now we have
orange we have an orange one that's
ready explode right here
um we could match this and that'll
explode that pepper but we don't have
any other big orange ones at the moment
so
what i'm going to do is i'm going to
make this t-shape match
and that will grow those i'm going to
match the purple
here because that'll match orange and
purple
that started the chain reaction with the
orange now i have a lot of big orange
ones
i have a big green one here
i'm gonna match these four yellow that's
gonna explode the green one and whenever
whenever i do that other ones are gonna
fall down so that'll give us a uh a bit
of a chain reaction
all right so
looking around i see that
i have quite a few
stage four orange
and one stage five orange so i could
match these
um
i can match these and then that will
probably start it
or else i could match the green
that'll shoot a fire uh that'll shoot a
shock wave this way
get this one ready to explode
or i can match these five purple right
here and that's gonna um
move a lot of peppers around
all right so this is what i wanted to
show you
now this orange one is ready to explode
this purple one's ready to explode
i'm gonna use the shock wave from
combining these four green peppers to
explode this orange one and i'm gonna
hope that somewhere around here
something falls
so that
i can get a chain reaction
and as you can see the orange is dead
and that will start a pepper panic
and you'd see as the peppers fall then i
get a lot of other matches um
and that's that
okay so what i'm going to do now is i'm
going to pause the video and then i'm
going to put it on a more difficult
level
and i'm going to see if i can get a
pepper panic started on one of those
all right so we're going to try out
level 16. um this is one of the early
levels and one of the first ones
that uh most people have trouble with
the difference in this board is is that
we have very small areas to match our
peppers
and um this is a this is a theme that
you're going to run into several times
throughout the game
and the problem is is that
there's not enough area to have a lot of
grown peppers sitting around so
what we're going to do on this one is
we're going to
go with what the board gives us as far
as
matches are concerned we don't have a
lot of choices so we have to kind of
work from that
and then we're going to
rather than
explode our peppers we're going to try
to get a bunch of
big ones
sitting around on the board
like you can see here i have one green
one that's grown
now i have one that's yellow i could
match this and explode this yellow one
but there's no other yellow peppers on
the board for it to uh combine with
like it won't grow any other one so it's
not gonna be the best move
now we got a couple more
another green one here
the purple will get a little bit bigger
those kind of matches are good where you
i grew my green pepper to stage five
plus i got when those peppers move they
got this orange one to grow for me so
those are the kind of things that you
want to look for
and i'm just gonna keep growing peppers
all right now i have a couple stage five
green i have stage five yellow
and i also have some purple
so basically what we're gonna do is now
that we have some of these peppers grown
we're going to look for
a move that will
displace a lot of peppers and also
um
all right so now we've exploded some
and we still have green and orange
they're both ready to go
i can match this green one here
but i still have four moves so i'm gonna
i'm gonna try to match a couple others
first
same thing i could i could explode this
i'd rather
wait just a little bit longer
alright so now we have quite a few ready
to go
um
and this is our last move so i'm going
to explode the orange and then hope that
i get some
other peppers to match like that
in the process and hopefully that'll
give us a full chain reaction that'll
start
10.
no luck
let's try one more time
that's what makes these kind of levels
difficult is that you know like it said
you have to get a little bit of help
from the peppers and you have to uh the
only way that you can really
maximize that is to have more peppers
that are ready to match whenever you go
you see there i made a couple t-shaped
matches those are good they grew these
peppers and they also grew some peppers
around them
matches like this one are good i'm going
to match these purple and that's also
going to match the yellow
those are good to
you know use
conserve moves as much as you can
same with that you know the green match
and the orange latch
um this is kind of early i'm going to
try to get lucky here i'm going to match
these this is going to also match the
orange and then we'll see we'll have a
couple peppers explode and we'll see
so you see like there's no other grown
peppers around on the board so it's you
know the chain reaction ends at two
all right now we got a couple of those
let's see what else we can do
you see i'm kind of just working around
the ones that i already have
all right now i have three stage five
orange so that's that's pretty good
again we have yellows and oranges
that looks pretty good there
so you see that by having those yellow
the orange peppers ready and then
exploding the yellows
as the peppers disappeared and they fell
i was able to get the oranges to start
and at the end you know there were
enough orange peppers fell onto the
board so that the chain reaction could
go all the way to 10 and the start of
pepper panic
hope that helps and makes sense if you
have any questions um leave some
comments below
um we get back to you real quick um
if you know if you like this article
share it with your friends
on facebook or twitter
and um if you got any
any other things that you'd like to see
articles about let us know and we'll uh
see what we can do
thanks